this one's both running late and without
the green screen and honestly I'm going
to tell you right now there's probably
going to be the way it is right through
the rest of the series I've just got a
packed month but with episodes this good
I'm still going to find the time to do
this stuff and tell you guys what I
think about it
flat line I can't even really begin to
list the things that I like about this
episode I don't want to go so far as to
say I love everything my the degree to
which I enjoyed it varies but everything
was positive there really was no
negative in this story from the concept
behind the sort of creatures and beings
that the doctor's dealing with which is
just a fascinating concept just to even
wrap your head around and then the way
that they sort of crippled the doctor a
little bit and render him less capable
of dealing with the issue than he
normally is and Clara really has to step
up her game and with Clara this is about
as good as I've ever seen her she really
steps up takes charge and I think the
situation really puts her sort of in the
mentality of the doctor I think she
starts to get a better handle on him and
I think that it's a benefit to their
relationship again I stick to what I
said before which is that I don't really
want her to stick around that much
longer but I I really do like her this
series she just works so much better
with Capaldi than she ever did with
Smith this episode just really has
everything it's fun it's funny it's
fast-paced when it needs to be it's
creepy and disturbing there's some
really unnerving imagery in this one
which is really well done the characters
are investigating they're on the Run
they're in a Siege situation I mean
really as I say all this I'm thinking
this should be too many elements this
should be too much stuff and it doesn't
all work but it does it all works this
series as a whole has just been markedly
excellent execution not every initial
concept has been gold but they haven't
stumbled in the execution of any of them
they have all been done about as well as
I think these ideas can be done
everybody's just on top of the game from
the writing to the shooting to the
special effects to the doctor to Clara
everything's in top form and this thing
is really just riding the rest right now
it's just so much fun and it is darker
than the doctor has been for a while it
definitely when you look at the series
as a whole so far but it's a tone that
really suits Capaldi's interpretation of
the doctor he really strikes you as the
kind of guy who almost sort of seeks out
the darkness when the doctors always
thrived on conflict and danger and
whatever else but he tends to stumble
into it a lot you really get the feeling
that capality if he wasn't just running
into it he would be seeking it actively
there's a fairly High number of guest
stars in this one who all who work well
some are around longer than others but
they all work none of them are dead
weight even the one who like immediately
is questioning everything that's going
on you know he's the normal sort of
stubborn I don't want to listen this is
impossible we're not gonna follow you
character still works they went all out
in the way that the character handles
and then the way he sort of pays off at
the end it just it it works it shouldn't
work but it works that's almost like the
mantra for the series as a whole that
shouldn't work but dang it it does so I
don't think there's too much more more
to say about this see it right away if
you haven't already so here's your
question for this week of the episodes
where the Tardis is either disabled or
the doctor is stuck in it what's your
favorite episode some examples of this
will be stuff like the Satan pit in The
Impossible Planet the doctor's wife the
girl who waited those are just a few off
the top of my head so disabled tardis or
can't get out of the TARDIS either one
what's your personal favorite episode of
that type whatever it is drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned
thank you